hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
episode of Game of Thrones tonight and I
thought we talked about someone who is
notably absent from the first episode
Arya who is on her way to Braavos the
last time we saw her this is mostly
gonna be about the faceless men in the
house of black and white the place that
Arya is going to the place that she's
using Jack and her guards coin to get to
does careful for spoilers on everything
that's happened on the show so far
right now our point of entry to the
faceless men is Jack and hook are
someone we haven't seen a long time Arya
Starks spent most of season 3 and season
4 massaging that coin that he gave her
the Braavosi coin his instructions to
her were that she could give that coin
to any Braavosi captain and it would
secure her passage to Braavos if she
wanted not of a whole lot of explaining
beyond that but it's a really big deal
which is why when she gave the coin to
the captain at the end of season 4 he
pooped his pants a little bit for the
most part you can think of the faceless
men is a quasi-religious order of
assassins that's headquartered in
Braavos their home base is the house of
black and white which is a temple of
worship so they serve a lot of functions
beyond just killing people like all
religious orders they do worship a God
the many-faced God but inside the temple
of black and white
there are altars to many many many gods
it's a nice twist on the idea that many
faced God but the many faced God is a
single deity with many different aspects
a lot of people think that the
many-faced God is also the stranger one
of the Andals seven gods
George R Martin hasn't confirmed or
denied this so it's still open to
speculation the reason why the faceless
men are so cool is because they you know
for all intents and purposes are the
best assassins in the world the most
highly trained assassins they're also
the most expensive if you remember way
back in season one during the small
council meeting they were trying to
figure out what to do with Daenerys
Targaryen when they first heard that she
was marrying Khal Drogo someone tossed
out that they should just hire faceless
men to take care of her but they decided
that it was way too expensive way too
expensive for Robert Baratheon he's
obviously in a lot of debt so in order
to hire a faceless man you have to be
incredibly rich that's why any time a
faceless man pops up in the books you
know people always wonder if one of the
Lords of Westeros or like the Martel's
or the iron bank of Braavos hired them
just because there are only a handful of
people that could legitimately afford
them the takeaway is that if there's a
assassination plot going on somewhere in
the world there's probably someone
incredibly rich behind it they don't
just kill people on whim they have very
specific rules it's unclear how the
show's gonna change this typically
whenever the show does like a really big
group from the books it simplifies
things so they might just hit the really
big signposts the faceless men actually
have a really interesting history that
go way back to the time of the Valerians
they actually they started out in the
Valyrian slave mines I know a lot of
people theorized that the Valyrian Doom
is tied to over mining in the vit
illyrian Peninsula a big part of the
Valerians MO is that they converted
conquered peoples into slave workers to
work in their minds the volcanoes that
eventually went nuclear around Valyria
were just really rich in minerals so in
these slave mines you had people
speaking all kinds of different
languages because the the Bulgarians had
conquered so many different lands as
really put upon slaves or want to do
they they prayed for deliverance from
death from each of their gods that they
worshipped other slaves heard these
whispers to all these different gods and
decided all these different slaves were
praying to the same God that became the
basis of the many-faced God so what you
have is you know many gods many faces
becoming would God with many faces many
aspects the the slaves essentially
started giving gifts of mercy or
deliverance to people that asked for it
the faceless man's gift of mercy is
essentially the gift of death the gift
of deliverance from the burden of life
you can think of it as assisted suicide
so the faceless men don't kill with
malice they kill to help people so now
you have an idea of why jaqen H'ghar is
so Zen about killing all those people at
Harrenhal for Arya the circumstances for
those events were slightly different he
was paying a debt to arya like i said
they do work as mercenaries so you can
pay them and name someone to be killed
after the Duman Valyria though they
established themselves as a proper order
in Braavos and created the temple of
black and white I did do a video about
about the map of Braavos and wear you
know big locations were inside the city
so I might do an update of that just
because that video is super old
technically inside their order faceless
man is just one of many functions so not
all people that worked inside that
temple black and white that join their
order become faceless men and there are
also women too so you know technically
you'd be a faceless woman in that case
I'm expecting the show to cut out about
just
Sidora whenever we see him I'll explain
some of the changes that they made from
the books I know a lot of people are
wondering out jack and the guard changed
his face you can think of it as more of
a technique than magic like glamouring
just to make the distinction between the
two you know in both cases you're
changing your appearance but glamouring
is full-on magic like you change your
entire appearance faceless men just
changed their faces but they can change
their facial structure too so one is
magic the other is just a practical
technique but it does involve using
someone else's face as in like a mask
sometimes when people die especially at
their temple they'll take their faces
they'll take the dead people's faces so
that they can use them later as
disguises what I'm hoping is is that
we'll get to see them do this on the
show I know it sounds like it really
gruesome practice but it's actually
pretty cool inside the house of black
and white there is a series of sub
levels you know with specific functions
being performed on each there are a
number of different people you might
bump into inside the house in black and
white you have priests acolytes faceless
men and then you have people who come to
worship or people who come to die a lot
of people come to the faceless men to
receive the gift of death the temple of
black and white though is is most famous
for its faceless men and you know
depending on who the target is their
price goes up you know there's always
the question is to what they do with the
money that they earn the interesting
thing though is that there is no target
that is too big you can ask them to kill
anyone as long as you can meet their
price so for instance if you ask them to
kill just like a street thug they might
not charge you a lot of money but if you
wanted them to kill Daenerys Targaryen
they would probably charge you enough to
buy a small Kingdom everybody knows
about there they're two big Valyrian
sayings on the show Valar morghulis all
men must die and Valar dohaeris all men
must serve I actually I think you know
the faceless men is somewhat of a
combination of that like the idea behind
them all men must serve death
Ahri's on this really interesting path
we see her recite her prayer all the
time she keeps adding names to the list
so the tease is that hopefully at some
point she will gain the skills of the
faceless men and take revenge on all
these people but revenge isn't part of
the faceless men's MO so it's a bit of a
paradox if she becomes a faceless man
she won't be able to get revenge on
these people unless some
one else hires her to kill them jaqen
H'ghar for instance in the previous
seasons he doesn't just go around
killing whoever he wants
he has very specific targets that are
given to him he gets sent on missions
just like any other mercenary so the
really big question for aria is is if
she's going to be able to let go of her
desire for revenge to become this new
person that she's trying to be this new
faceless person that's actually a good
jumping-off point so here's my big
question for you guys do you think that
Aria if she wants to become a faceless
person is going to be able to put aside
her desire to kill all these people back
in Westeros ultimately you know thinking
forward to like book six seven you know
whatever beyond that I don't think she's
gonna be able to do it a good side step
is Jon Snow and his vows to the Nights
Watch thinking about all the things that
he did when he was on the side mission
in season three when he was trying to
infiltrate the wildlings he broke a lot
of his vows even though it was for a
good reason I think the same thing is
gonna happen to Arya she's gonna end up
breaking whatever vows she ends up
making whatever new vow she makes in the
name of justice that's one of the most
fun things to watch on the show is this
like you know can these characters
especially the younger characters commit
to really elaborate plans and set aside
you know the things that they really
want so everybody get really pumped to
see Braavos tonight and don't forget new
round of the giveaway starts whenever I
post my episode 2 review I'll post that
after the episode airs be sure to
subscribe to get it if you're just
finding me for the first time just in
case you guys are confused too I named
the giveaway winners in my Q&A videos
that I post on Monday night so why you
guys wait for all that stuff to post you
can click here for my episode 1 video
and you can click here to learn all
about the sons of the harpy that group
inside myrin thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]